with shroud dominating the streaming
world it's easy to forget that he used
to be a CS GoPro and for those who
didn't get to catch him on stage just
how good was he the that trout
could do in CS simple could never do
what bro what are you talking about man
Trout's career spanned from 2013 to 2017
and much of that time he spent on cloud
nine and throughout the years shroud
blessed us with some truly iconic
moments one two
unfortunately it's hard to say the same
about his results shroud's tournament
earnings are just under 220 thousand
dollars with the biggest win happening
at Pro League season 4 where shroud was
one of the highest rated players we
always see it against one head shot he
gets the second one of the sky but a
shroud's pro career fizzled out after
clone 2017 his notoriety in the world of
streaming turned him into a household
name and he soon became the Rowdy boy we
all know and love today sure shroud
might not be the greatest csgo player of
all time but in his prime his mechanical
skills could not be ignored can he do it
again he shot